after the terrorist attacks on 911 sir
my field of which I'm guilty of Homeland
Security national security sort of i
think sold the american public an
unobtainable dream and you know part of
it was political i admit that and the
rush to war in iraq but i think part of
it was just a way of thinking about
Homeland Security that we could be
invincible that we could be fortress
America and that's just not true we know
that from our day-to-day experience and
we knew it on September 12 right that
this country is all about flow about the
flow of people and goods and ideas and
the more security apparatus you put on
it the less we will be able to be the
kind of citizens we want to be I I often
say as a mother I think it's my
god-given right to go on amazon.com and
have the delivery the next day think of
the vulnerabilities right that exist in
just that one moment right you got to
move something from here to there to get
to my house and we have to think of
ourselves and our own vulnerabilities as
not only desirable but also choices
we've made and so that's how I now think
about risk right that we are going to
accept a level of risk from whatever
harms come our way and we can try to
prevent them and prepare for if they
happen but we also should get better
about responding and thinking about how
we would protect our own families and
communities if something were to happen
but this idea that you know the idea
after nine eleven that never again was
going to be our standard right never
again I understand that we were
traumatized and it was delusional and
we've been successful at stopping that
kind of attack but you know the idea
that we're going to stop every in a sort
of loner who becomes radicalized in his
basement online and has easy access to
guns and can walk you know into us any
soft target the idea that any security
apparatus is going to stop that guy it's
just it's delusional and I
think we have to sort of accept that
while there are risks out there they are
they far outweighed by the lack of
violence in our society but that those
risks are just ones that we have to
accept I also think that from those who
were critical of the bush administration
in those years as I was that it that it
created a sort of counter narrative
right that the reaction to it was to
think it was all a bunch of BS right
that it didn't actually that there were
no threats or that nothing that the
government could do was ever going to
help us and you know these guys are just
you know right-wing fanatics who want to
put up walls everywhere and i think the
truth lies somewhere in between for me
that that moment of there's there's a
space in between you know you know what
i call you tuning out and freaking out
was Hurricane Katrina for me was was a
recognition it's just several years
after nine eleven that a country that's
so focused on sort of never again right
and answers stopping 19 guys from
getting onto for airplanes had failed a
city and and let it drown and I think
that we have to sort of find that space
in between those two extremes and
recognize that there are risks but that
we actually can do a lot to minimize
those risks to ourselves and so like one
perfect example is look I'm a
counterterrorism expert right that I
know that the greatest risk to my kids
when they go to a movie theater or
wherever else is going to be guns right
we just live in a society I also know I
alone will not solve the gotten the gun
challenge but I think in terms of
finding that middle ground about talking
about preparedness and Risk Reduction I
think most gun owners get that you know
five-year-olds and guns don't work well
together they get the idea of lock boxes
of even biometric identification or
fingerprint identification on guns I
think if we can begin to find even
common space on the greatest extreme in
our in our security and safety discourse
maybe we can start to make some progress